welcome to the two o'clock class as
opposed to the one o'clock class chess
for Knights I guess Knights are better
than rooks based on the names of the
classes okay and well first I'm going to
yell at the audience at home I'll get to
you guys later all right
so in my last video although it wasn't
my last one it was the last one now but
it's gonna be two videos ago for you
guys because across the street and you
guys should have complained that the
video was too short but instead you
complained about the editing the editing
was perfect okay you guys just you don't
know what's going on this is the magic
world of Hollywood over here you guys
are at home and you're like I got to go
get the drink and I can't follow the
game and I don't know what's going on
okay so you got to stop that you got to
focus okay and this is actually a kids
class unlike the previous video which
was not a kids class this is a kids
class if you can call them kids two four
six eight kids terrible aren't you guys
ashamed that your brethren did you show
up they look pretty ashamed okay no
talking yeah this is live right now they
can hear you okay now today we're going
to talk about the French defense and
it's a very funny reason why because I
was asleep this morning because it was
like 11:30 so I hadn't woken up yet and
then my girlfriend texted me in the
French defense how come this and how
come that and I was like this is why and
she's like I don't agree with that
you're an idiot
rawr and I was like but what about this
issue so that's stupid then I said what
about this Sophie she goes no you're
terrible alright so that was how it went
ok now we're going to talk about all
that stuff because all that texting took
about half an hour so this should take
about half an hour cuts a half an hour
class okay and then you'll edit it down
to like five minutes okay
sort of like The Sopranos for regular TV
edited to five minutes now we're it's
all at the French defense that will
actually get the specific position later
the French defense black has one goal
black wants to play d5 but black doesn't
want to
of his or her queen okay because after
tanks and you want to take back you got
to move your queen or you could try to
take back with a knight okay or if it's
the one o'clock class you could attack
the pawn or if it's the other class
that's not the one o'clock class which
is even the chest for beginners what's
it called no no there's another one
where they teach you upstairs what it
doesn't have a name yeah that Bishop g4
attacking the Queen okay or if it's you
at home King d7 alright so the point of
e six is I want to play d5 but I want my
pawn defended so white plays d4 black
plays d5 and that's the French defense
now in theory the French defense was
invented in a telex game you don't know
what a telex is because you guys exactly
because you guys are kids and if you're
an adult you would note it is either I
actually used the telex once in 1984 I
was in Moscow and I hadn't talked to my
parents in three weeks so I said the
metallics because they didn't have the
internet so then phones didn't it wasn't
so good the phone don't do that that's
where you do this and then they get into
somewhere else so there was a match
between Paris and London and then they
played by telex no talking no talking
and then this is what black did and
black was Paris so they called the
French defense they probably let's point
out why that happened but that's what I
read I'm sure it's true one of my
favorite French defense games is a
Murphy game where he was blackhat
wondering like 15 moves but I've shown
that game on your videos like 50 times
we don't want them to complain at home
because free content from grandmasters
does nothing you can do a complain
non-stop okay now in the French defense
white has several things that they can
do and I'm funny story about the French
don't make a noise like that okay you're
making him look good and that's
impossible
alright so the French defense I was
playing master cero on a long time ago
maybe four or five years ago talking and
yessir plans the French defense he also
plays another opening so I was like hmm
maybe hopefully the French
defense and if he does I like to play
pawn takes pawn that's called the
exchange variation because I'm
exchanging and so I went to my computer
and I looked at every yes or sara one
game he ever played in his life that's
on a computer where he pled the French
defense and I found zero examples of
this smooth so I was like huh
anyway the game ended he did not play
the French defense he pled the caro-kann
he beat me in six and a half hours and I
said you know before the game I thought
you might buy the French and I was
looking at the exchange French but I
couldn't find any game as that you ever
played in it he goes no nobody's ever
done that against me so he's played this
position with black over a hundred times
and he said zero people if they pawn
takes pawn that's like what okay if
you're playing at a lower level you guys
know what I'm talking about then you're
going to face pawn takes pawn quite a
bit and you have a symmetrical position
that positions the same and it's White's
turn to move so white has a small
advantage but not nothing serious yeah
that's not a testing move the testing
moves are Knights III defending the pawn
Knight d2 also defending the pawn and E
5 and we're going to look mainly at E 5
because that's the hardest for this
class now the class is confused
the reason the class is confused is when
you guys play chess and you at home if
you could play chess the mean the main
games you guys have have open centers
everything's open you could do whatever
you want okay TI style right exactly
but in the closed position you can do
anything this Bishop can't get out of
here this Bishop can't go here or here
because you'll lose it this knight can't
go here because you lose it your queen
can't go here or here because you lose
it so this sort of blocked nobody in the
center could move anything well the
difference is since white has this space
and black can't do anything black has an
advantage his D pawn is defended by a
pawn and whites deep ah
is not defended by a pond and this point
can't go back here and defend it that's
illegal
so what blood does is you starts
attacking that pond overextended maybe
place see five and blacks whites like so
what and black does it again and white
defends it again now in this position
black has two moves that are common in
Grandmaster play Queen b6 obviously
attacking the D pawn again and Bishop d7
developing the bishop now when I was
asleep
and I got this text the text was after
Bishop d7 why does white play a3 and
white doesn't have to play a3 that was
just the game that she was looking at it
she was like why did the guy do that so
I gave very good explanation that's
because I'm Grandmaster I said well in
some positions
what black wants to play Knight b4 or
Bishop before but that's never going to
happen
never ever right and I said and
sometimes white plays before and when I
say sometimes I mean usually anyway she
doesn't like that explanation she's like
wow White's not developing his pieces
playing a3 playing on the side that's
terrible
I was taught develop your pieces so I
gave an example
I said let's say you develop your bishop
now after takes takes I could play
Knight before attacking your Bishop or I
could play Bishop b4 check and then I
could play by Knight to e7 and I said if
white spawns on a3 which is what the guy
played it's very hard to get these two
pieces out if the knight goes here it
blocks the bishop the bishop goes here
it blocks the knight from going there so
a3 has a lot of good ideas now I give
another example because sometimes when
you look at opening a you want to look
at other openings for comparison what's
the name of this opening Sicilian and
the most common variation of the
Sicilian if you're a grandmaster is say
say it again
is that is the night ourf named after
miguel night or from poland okay
although he didn't didn't live in poland
because he had to get out of there no
ago talking a six is correct good
talking a six does everything a three
does it stops White's pieces from going
to be five just like a three stops black
and white wanted to play b4 in the other
opening black wants to play b5 at some
point so the night or f-- has a very
similar idea to the move a three here
we're protecting the be four square so
black can never go there and maybe why
it will play b4 now yeah now one of the
funny variations in the French after
Queen b6 white can blunder his deep on
by playing Bishop to d3 and if you're
good at counting we got three guys on
the deep line and we got two guys
defending it and by the way we have
three guys defending it right but we
blocked one of them
it's like Family Guy it's a trap okay so
after we trade no no no screaming raise
your hand if you want to say something
don't raise your hand you okay so if we
try to win upon is winning upon is good
Bishop Shak and we have a discovered
attack on the Queen because you
discovering it okay so they're arguing
about whether white should win a queen
or queen for a bishop both are good
choices I would prefer a free queen okay
so that's one of the traps in the French
defense is you can't take this pawn
right away now based on your knowledge
of this trap and you don't want white to
play Bishop b5 check winning your Queen
right what moves should black play you
with your hand up this should be seven
where'd you hear that from that's
correct and then there's many many many
many Grand Minister games that start
this position many and usually white
sacrifices the pawn and black says how
come I didn't develop my Kings side and
he's like oh yeah cuz I'm a pawn up okay
now when you're a lower rated player or
a beginner or not an advanced player
like you at home in you here you're very
dogmatic okay and the reason you're
dogmatic if you're at home is because
your rating crazy stuff on the internet
through dogmatic and if you're here it's
because you don't know anything's you
just say that one thing that you know
over and over and over again wait Ben
Simon's not here just like God okay now
he has to find it edit it out no that's
that's hilarious okay if he doesn't if
he doesn't if he doesn't find that out
he's going to be in a lot of trouble
don't talk unless you raise your hand
and don't raise your hand all right
don't talk unless you raise your hand we
do have security here okay now so uh yes
now dogmatic means you know something
and then you just keep saying it 500
times in a row and you discount
everything else so for example let's say
White Castle and you are like oh boy a
free pond and it's true black is ahead
upon so you can say black is ahead upon
you can say it a thousand times so
blacks winning because I was taught when
you're ahead upon you're winning and
then your friend might say it's move
nine and you didn't move any of these
pieces yet and you moved your Queen
twice and you move your knight twice and
white White's already castle and it's
White's turn to move blacks never get a
castle you could say White's winning and
in fact both of those things are true
except for the winning part White has
more development White's castled blacks
going to make some more Queen moves by
the way and black self of one so some of
you might want to be a pawn ahead and
some of you might want to have the
attack that's why people argue okay it's
not that one is true they're both true
and that's why chess is difficult so
that's a pawn sacrifice now a lot of
people don't want to sacrifice upon so
they don't play Bishop to d3 they play
Bishop to e2 and their queen is
defending their pawn however this ship
looks pretty good on d3 okay you too
looks a little more passive okay the
other problem that White has in the
French is that it's very hard to get
these pieces out and of course the
knight wants to go to c3 if you've
played chess before probably your
Knights gone to c3 right but when your
pawns on c3 your Knights not going to c3
therefore black doesn't want to trade
pawns really early a grandmaster would
never do that
because then then I can go to c3 so we
want to leave that pawn on c3 so white
can never do that
if white puts the knight on D to his
bishop on c1 will never move on the
other hand if we play the variation that
we just discussed with Bishop to d7 and
a3 it's possible White's going to play
b4 and then put his Bishop on b2 and
fianchetto is Bishop that happens
sometimes
okay so this is a very hard position
because with all the puns on white it's
hard to get this bishop
with all the puns on dark squares it's
hard to get this Bishop somewhere and
when black plays Queen b6 very early
which is very common it's very hard to
move this Bishop because you lose this
pawn right now somebody he used to work
at the club and very recently retired
was our scholastic director Bill
Thompson and Bill Thompson always had
white in this position he's rated about
1700 and he played Bishop to e3 because
you can't play Queen takes pawn yet
right and if somebody played Queen to b6
attacking this pawn he would play Queen
to d2 defending his pawn okay and then
he would just he would develop his other
pieces and castle and so forth that's
what Bill Thompson liked to do and most
people don't play Bishop III so when he
played it as a plunger like huh and
that's all he ever did so he knew a lot
about his opponents were confused early
right make sense he played his own
variation of what he stole it from some
grandmaster okay so if you know the
opening and you know moves that are
uncommon but you play them a lot and
your opponent's like huh I don't know
that well that's uncommon okay then you
can't really be a pop star because
you're not common
and the kids here that never heard of
common so they're like one actually
there's a photo I saw on the internet
with Louisa Ashley uncommon and the CEO
Starbucks yeah that was I saw it like
three days ago so the French defense
that's the advanced variation
it's very complicated some people don't
want to play e5 they want to develop
their pieces so they play Knight c3
after Knight c3 one common move is to
pin the night that's called the win Omar
variation and some of you and some of
you at home have heard of Bobby Fischer
not all of you but some of you and my
dad who is a chess master play Bobby
Fischer once in 1963 and that was the
position they had yeah it was 54 moves
it took like six hours and nowadays
grandmasters play e5 but this game was
played in 1963
so Fischer played a three takes takes
takes Queen G for attacking two pawns
Knight f6 rook GA rope g6 and this is a
funny game because White's made a
thousand Queen moves and both sides have
a terrible pawn structure so chess is
hard and the game went into a Bishop and
pawn endgame if you go to the internet
and type in Fischer Feingold you'll find
the game and if you're at home or you're
here you might say Oh button Feingold I
know him I wasn't alive in 1963 so it
wasn't my game and you'll be glad to
know that my dad was a chess master my
brother is a chess master my son's a
chess master my first wife is a woman's
international master and my second wife
was an 1800 player
so when you see Feingold you know i wait
a minute who is that you could assume
it's me and if the guy won
then you could assume that now a funny
story I like stories in the New York
Times they have a chest article they
used to they got rid of it because the
New York
is a great paper anyway they used to
have a chest column every Sunday and
Tuesday then every Tuesday then never
when they had a chest column in 1992
they put into the game
John fedora wits been Feingold from the
US Open then fine go got crushed and
they were like wow been finals terrible
and then I wrote the newspaper and I
said that wasn't me that was my dad and
they never put a correction in because
you know so if you have an issue of the
New York Times from 1990 to the August
the chest column it says that I lost
again I didn't play right so that
happened sometimes so there's a lot of
Feingold's out there and so and
sometimes they hurt the chess club like
my son's here today but oh man you got
to find all the times I said yeah I said
it once although she said it like nine
times when the kids say what do you do
yeah
what'd it feel like I was playing bridge
and I trumped I don't have to the
context is important one of your playing
bridge and your opponent's Donald Trump
you say Trump a lot they're not sure
which what I mean okay very good
all right who's the quietest what if I
if I give a long talk about Hilary Swank
but you don't know what chiller I'm
talking about whoo that would be talking
okay now some of you are like well I
don't want to get pinned so when your
opponent goes here you start crying
because you're Knights Efendi for those
people we have a move for you we can
defend our pawn with our night and now
get pinned
hooray anyone 92 now if your opponent
pins you you're like Yeah right like you
could pin me and so nobody plays Bishop
before Hitler see through that silly the
problem with 92 is our Bishop can't make
a lot of moves right okay so some
grandmasters play Knight d2 some
grandmasters play Knight c3 and some
play e5 those are the most common moves
and 92 is not bad because later in the
game when the bishop moves somewhere
we're going to maneuver our Knight over
to the Kings side or I could go to the
Queen side or I could go to the center
so it's on d2 when it's 10
Prairie it's not that bad okay one of my
favorite games you can look it up at
home is the game played in the u.s.
championship Oh about four or five years
ago between Hikaru Nakamura many time us
champion and Yuri Schulman who won the
US Championship once and they started
from this position and Yuri Schulman won
a very nice game with a lot of tactics
and Yuri Schulman did something I've
never heard of who is he he was black
Yuri Schulman always plays the French
okay now if you wanted cheat and you
want to cheat legally go talking here's
how you do it let's say you want to
learn an opening let's say the French
and you're like oh man the French that's
a lot of work there's books on the
fridge there's a thousand game that I
want to look at that I'm tired what you
could do which I do is I find a really
strong player who only plays that
opening that I look at their games
because they already did all the work
okay so Yuri Schulman always plays the
French and his us rating was 2700 so he
plays the French every game and he
studies the French a lot so I look at
his games and I'll play like him he
already did all that work
why should I do any work okay and I
don't play the French so I didn't do
that but I'll find a grandmaster who's
much better than me top ten in the world
who plays opening I play and I play like
them because they play pretty good
well all I can tell you is that you'll
beat me that would be I actually play
every opening so that nobody can prepare
for me in fact when I was your age I
only played the French then I got older
then I stopped okay so then when I say
always play the French what it's legally
possible no talking okay now after
Knight c3 we could also take the pawn we
could play Knight f6 or we could play
Bishop to b4 those are the most common
moves and after that there's even more
moves I'll show you a really funny
variation call them the kuchen so you
can see how funny chess is here 'if I've
is the most common move but some people
pinned the nine
and here this should be sevens the most
common move to unpin late but some
people pin that night all the nights are
pin and when I'm teaching the one
o'clock class I show them this position
a lot because this is the two kinds of
pins absolute and relative you see what
I'm saying is the two o'clock class this
snakes pinned if you move it you lose
your queen in this night spin and you
can't move it because you check and at
your efj I've some of you are confused
luckily you walked in the room confused
so nothing really changed right okay now
in this position you'll notice the
Knights attacked and the knight can't
move that would seem good for white
however this is a normal opening how can
we have a normal opening and blacks
losing a piece now I'm going to tell you
a secret if you listen when your Bishop
is pinning somebody's night to their
Queen and your pawn attacks it 99% of
the time this is the right move for
black there's only one move for black
that doesn't lose a piece sleeve does
your mom know you know do you think she
knows she went like Lu I know but she
didn't want to give the answer away what
not here you know I'm in how does buzz
you how does black not lose a piece for
nothing what does he do that just that
just delays the inevitable
you're still pin what is it that guy's
right pawn each six you attack the piece
that's pinning you if white is very
insistent on pinning you then you attack
him again okay now in this position
you'll be surprised what the most common
move is now I've actually done that and
I lost in 85 moves in the u.s.
championship but about about 12 years
ago - Jesse cried he has the right name
because when the game ended I was crying
he was crying yeah true story though he
was crying I was crying because I was
okay so the most common move is Bishop
to d2 no talking now the Knights snap
pinned and this Knights attacked and the
main main main main main line is Bishop
c3 BC 394 Queen g4 and grandmasters
argue how to save this pawn some play g6
and some play King f8 depends which
Grandmaster you ask well cast well no
nobody nobody does it with their Rahman
and castling is risky castling is risky
it's that not the best then you'd have
to cry a lot okay so the McCutchen is
complicated right and also one of the
tricky new moves when I say new it's
like 15 years old is Bishop e3 not I'm
hitting the night okay
and I've actually played this with with
white and it's not good for white yeah
and this is considered better for black
my opponent played Queen f6 knight c6
Castle queenside and whites King doesn't
really have a safe place okay but I
tried okay and if you go to the Internet
you can finally get my loss to cry okay
that's what happens when you play
opening you never played before then you
lose now
I'm going to show you something funny
it's a gambit this ship before I just
showed you but also Bishop e7 I'm
hitting the Knight e5 97 most fan
masters play Bishop takes Bishop there's
a world champion who never heard of
there like one you heard of him he was
the world champion after kappa blanka
he was the next one he beat kappa blanka
that's why he was the role champion
yeah Bhavana was after but that Baba I
didn't be to be kappa blanka
they did play they play elephant's right
hey Gino I Alekhine was no longer world
champion Oh what happened him no he won
he got a concussion
no he died he was he died when he was
the world champion that's never happened
before or since
so there was no world champion so they
had a tournament with six players I
think and they played 24 games no
talking
yeah and then there was a big tournament
and it was won by the guy you said
Botvinnik so Babak won this big
tournament with a lot of people million
rounds now Alec I'm you said has a
defense named after him he also has this
fun sacrifice named after him in this
position instead of taking the bishop
Alec I'm like h4 and then black said oh
boy a free pawn and Alec I said oh boy
my rook has an open line so when you
castle over there I'm going to meet you
and Alec I said oh boy I'm going to play
Knight d5 and take on c7 so actually
more than half the grandmasters now they
don't take that pawn they're afraid they
think they're going to get crushed okay
so that was a pawn sacrifice you don't
have to take the pawn you could play
like a six year and then white would
never play this and checkmate you if you
play c5 right away and now when white
plays this white might go here and then
you'll cry because if you take the
knight you lose your queen right that's
funny how we're seeing out a six and A
three are good defensive moves stopping
your opponent from crushing you so the
French defense is complicated okay now I
used to play something called the Fort
Knox okay and that was because it was
solid you couldn't break through it okay
unless you watch the movie Goldfinger no
no this true story okay so after the
knight goes to D 2 or C 3 it doesn't
matter we take
and now grandmasters today like to play
Knight to d7 and then nine to f6 but I
like to play Bishop to d7 and then I
play Bishop c6 then the one o'clock
class I get to take this Knight almost
every time but good players don't give
their night away for nothing they either
move it back or they defend it right
okay and then I play ninety seven and I
play Knight f6 I played this should be
seven and then black has all of his
pieces out but he's very solid and
cramped I like that that my opponent
goes crazy sacrificed again I win
something like that happens and the Fort
Knox is a very boring solid opening I
wouldn't recommend it what's good about
this point this way with black is it
doesn't matter if white goes here or
here I take the plot on you for either
way we get the same position see I have
to learn less okay good job so there's
the advanced French wear white advances
there's Knight c3 played by which world
champion against my dad you want use
that tendency like that Bobby Fischer
and there's 92 which Karpov likes to
play a lot
the tarush variation named after
Grandmaster Siebert tarush okay if you
don't like that move you can throw it in
the trash can or you could play the
caro-kann either way but that's not
funny okay but now I had a guy play the
Carroll Khan against me and I told my
friend William Shatner and he said Khan
he was really mad right you look at that
joke why you laugh all right okay so the
French defense is very interesting and
I'll tell you the main reason with the
French defense discussion today now when
you're a kid and you learn chess every
game is a 45 okay that's 99% of kids
games okay and then I'm like oh he's 45
again okay but if your opponent is
always doing a 45
that's every game they play and then you
don't play e5 then they're confused if
you're play somebody and they're like
yeah he's going to play e5 that's
everybody plays that that's all I know
and you pick up your epon and then I da
ya 85 and you go east six they're like
wait what's that so when you play
beginners and you play e6 they don't
know what e6 is okay and they don't face
e6 very often when you play stronger
players good players they face a 5d 6d
6d v c6 e5 they gotta learn all that
stuff so when you learn 6 and they have
to learn tender for openings advantage
you but if you play e5 they're like yeah
every game is e45 I know everything and
I play key five myself so not me I mean
that's what your opponent is saying
you've never not played you find the
ugly so the French defense is very
interesting because you get different
positions that you would get with E 4 E
5 and so you could have a lot of
experience playing an opening that's not
you 45 and then when you play somebody
else they've never seen it before
that you've seen it for years advantage
you so by going off the beaten path you
too can enjoy Robert Frost class
dismissed